- So, because you're doing
in Just Like That right now,
you know, Sex in the City,
the show has a whole new
life because, it's funny,
because all these streaming services,
everybody's like getting back into like.
- Got it, yes.
- So they're like watching the whole thing
and now they're getting in Just
Like That, like afterwards.
- Right.
- But my question is, you know,
our kids, like even like
certain music videos I did,
my daughter will be like,
you are wearing a crop top.
And I'm like getting called
out by my seven year old.
And so I'm like, I'm interested.
Like, are you scared when they
watch Sex in the City at all?
Like when they're older?
- You know, I've had
different thoughts about it
at different times.
One time Gemma and I were on a plane,
before Wilson came
and she was like, mommy,
the person in front of you, their monitor.
That girl looks like you.
And I was like that, that is me.
- Oh no.
- And I was like, what
show are they watching?
- What scene?
- What's going to happen?
What am I going to do?
It was fine.
It was the first movie.
It wasn't anything bad,
but she was young, right.
So it was like a little scary.
But now that she's older
and now that she's getting exposed
from her friends to all this stuff,
even though I'm very controlling.
- Yeah.
- I was thinking, I
mean, she knows about it.
She knows the vague topic.
We haven't gone into it,
but I'm thinking I'm going
to use it as like a teaching tool.
- That's clever.
- You know, because I
don't want them to feel...
- It's empowering, though, for women.
- Right, right.
I don't want her to feel embarrassed.
- Yeah.
- I don't want her to feel,
I want her to talk to me.
I'm a single mom.
It's super important.
Do you know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- Got to keep them talking right.
Got to keep the...
- Got to keep the open dialogue
or they'll learn it on the school bus.
- Exactly, right.
Exactly, exactly.
That's what I did too.
- Yeah.
- So, you know,
Sex in the City is kind of a
good educational type thing.
- Yeah.
- For later.
- No, totally and I think that,
it's one of those things though,
where I always find it interesting too.
Because I feel like
some people be like, oh,
I would shy away from doing it.
I was like, wait, you
weren't shy doing it.
It was empowering.
And it was cool.
And I think for the right age,
it's like important, okay.
- Right, that's what I'm thinking.
- Let's get that book
passed around in schools.
- I haven't done it yet.
Yeah, we got you some books.
- The birds and the bees.
- Yup, yup.